what is up with all the tragic
backstories Disney we know it can
sometimes make the characters more
interesting but you used to at least
leave the board Disney princes out of it
you think that was easy now it seems
like every Disney Prince has to have a
messed up origin story too
[Music]
and what you did to poor Prince Eugene
entangled the series it's just so sad we
all know that Disney Princesses have
unfortunate upbringing but now it seems
that the trend has extended to Disney
princes too
[Music]
and some of their stories are seriously
messed up keep watching to find out the
tragic pass of some of your favorite
Disney love interests Aladdin
riff-raff street rat we all know how
that song goes Aladdin is on everyone's
mind lately with the release of the
live-action remake and when you think of
Disney Princess with sad backstories
Aladdin might be the first one that
comes to mind
Aladdin grew up poor on the streets of
Agrabah he was orphaned at a very young
age
in the new version he says all he can
remember of his mom was a song that
she's saying to survive Aladdin had to
learn how to steal as he says in the
song he has to eat to live but he has to
steal to eat that's a really sad
existence thankfully he has a boo as a
companion yep just me and Abu Aladdin is
a diamond in the rough and deserves the
happy ending he got with Princess
Jasmine
Prince Hans okay we know Hans is a
villain but he's still a Disney Prince
and his backstory explains why he's so
evil we find out a little from the movie
frozen but the novel of frozen heart
talks a lot more about his past and
honestly we feel a little sorry for him
glad I caught you Hans Hans is the
youngest of 13 Prince's there was no way
he was going to roll a kingdom unless he
married but he suffered a lot of
physical and emotional abuse at the
hands of his older brothers and his dad
the King encouraged it he believed that
the strong should pick on the weak his
dad viewed Hans as a total useless
Prince he neglected Hans and played
favorites with the older boys it doesn't
excuse the way Hans acts but at least we
understand why he's such a villain if
only there was someone out there who
loved you Prince Naveen this
smooth-talking prince turned frog may
seem like he had a great childhood and
at first glance he kind of did but
growing up as a spoiled prince isn't
always a good thing
as a kid he was waited on hand and foot
by servants he even had servants to read
him bedtime stories
this means his parents probably weren't
around much so he turned into a total
snob who couldn't do anything for
himself he became completely lazy and he
partied way too much his parents the
king and queen of maldonia decided to
cut off his inheritance he had no money
and was completely clueless about
adulting there had to be a less extreme
way for his parents to teach him a
lesson
thankfully Tiana whips him into shape
and turning into a frog definitely
helped to once she became my wife that
made you the Beast Prince Adam who later
became the Beast is another spoiled
arrogant prince in the 1991 animated
movie he was cool simply because he was
rich that's why he was cursed by The
Enchantress
but plenty of rich people are kind and
know how to love the 2017 live-action
version gave us a lot more backstory
about the prince proposed by her Haggard
appearance the prince and the woman away
he loved his mother very much and she
was a wonderful woman but she passed
away when he was just a young kid Prince
Adams father was not a nice person
he raised Adam to be just like him Adam
grew up to be cruel and arrogant but his
household staff knew this sweet young
boy was still inside somewhere it just
took Belle's love to bring it out again
Crysta
we know that Kristoff isn't a prince yet
but he will be once he marries Anna
maybe that will happen in frozen to like
it
Christophe is another orphan Disney
character he was put into an orphanage
at a young age but he was far too
adventurous to live there
he kept sneaking out to the outdoors
eventually he left the orphanage to live
on his own as a kid he grew up
completely on his own until he rescued
Sven in the reindeer he would watch the
ice harvesters and learned how to do the
job himself he was finally adopted by
the trolls he loves them very much even
though he says they can be overbearing
and loud but growing up as a loner who
is raised by trolls caused Kristoff to
be suspicious of humans we
glad he now has a life with honor Prince
Eugene Eugene Fitzherbert aka Flynn
Rider starts with a similar story to
Aladdin he was an orphan who resorted to
stealing to survive and he wants nothing
more than to be rich he convinced
himself his parents were adventurers who
would one day return to rescue him from
the orphanage but they never did
entangled the series Eugene finds out
the truth of his lineage he was born a
prince he was the son of King Edmund
from the Dark Kingdom but when the
moonstone threatened to destroy the
kingdom Edmund ordered an evacuation
Eugene was taken by a servant and later
placed in the orphanage how sad is that
we knew he was more than just a common
thief we hope that he builds a
relationship with his father after
Cassandra is defeated he deserves it
so which Disney Prince is your favorite
let us know in the comments section
thanks for watching give this video a
big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe to the things we'll catch you
later
[Music]